DEMOCRATS AND THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE TELLS US
FROM LOS ANGELES.
>> GAVIN NEWSOM HAD AN
INAPPROPRIATE AFFAIR WITH HIS
EMPLOYEE.
>> THE TOP DEMOCRATS IN THE RACE
FOR CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR ARE
TAKING FIRE.
>> ANTONIO B WOULD GO SO DID THE
SAME WITH A REPORTER.
>> DEMOCRATIC CHALLENGER AMANDA
RENTERIA CALLED ON CANDIDATE
GIVEN NEWSOM TO STEP ASIDE.
>> I BELIEVE ELECTED OFFICIAL
SHOULD BE HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD.
AND NO MATTER WHAT THAT IS, WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ELECTED THE LEADERS WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN INVOLVED IN ABUSING THEIR
POWER ANYWAY.
>> A FORMER AIDE TO
HILLARY CLINTON SEES A DOUBLE
STANDARD, ESPECIALLY AMONG
PROGRESSIVES WHO CALL ON
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT IN OTHERS.
>> IT IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
INAPPROPRIATE IN EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE PAID IN EVERY WAY.
>> AND SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR, HE
HAD A SECRET ONGOING AFFAIR WITH
HIS SECRETARY, AT THE TIME HE
CALLED SLEEPING WITH A
SUBORDINATE TO A PERSONAL MATTER
IN.
SHE LOST HER JOB AND TAXPAYERS
PAID FOR HER COUNSELING.
>> THE THING THAT I SAID TO THE
VOTERS IN TAMPA AND CISCO, THAT
IN KNOWLEDGE, I APOLOGIZE FOR
IT.
>> CALIFORNIA SENATOR KEMAL
HARRIS ENDORSED NEWSOM, CHELSEA
HANDLER HELPED HIM RAISE
70 MILLION.
FROM SILICON VALLEY AND
HOLLYWOOD.
>> YES, IT IS TRUE.
>> ALSO ADMITTED TO HAVING AN
AFFAIR WITH A REPORTER THAT
COVERED HIS OFFICE, BUT HE
ENJOYS BROAD DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT
>> DOES IS NOT THAT BIG OF A
DEAL ANYMORE.
>> DAN WALTERS SAYS BECAUSE BOTH
AFFAIRS WERE CONSENSUAL, THE
MEDIA, LIBERAL DONORS, AND
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING THE OTHER
WAY.
>> THIS IS NOT TO KANSAS, THIS
IS CALIFORNIA.
AND PEOPLE TAKE A PRETTY
TOLERANT VIEW OF HUMAN FOIBLES.
>> RECENT POLLS SHOW NEWSOM WITH
30% OF THE VOTE, AND REPUBLICAN